um have like it's crazy because you you
call yourself hap Vamp or half Vamp has
like any of um Playboy Cardi's
interesting cult following of
white kids with dirty air forces come
out of the Woodworks saying wear The
Vamps nah I get a lot of I get a lot of
card fast
I'll be trying to maybe like putting
comments and [__] yeah I'd be trying to
call the fans chill man you should tell
them there's more than one vampire
obviously they never said it don't tell
anyone stop making a vows when they made
Carter you feel Miss different type of
events what's the best vampire movie
what's that what's that one
it's like a
what's that there's Lost Boys there's
blade there's no there's also some
really really suspects what's that one
at
good at a lot of things but acting is
not probably at the top of the you know
he's all right yeah but he he's good he
good [__] [__] [__] you feel me like
come on Soul Plane
a lot of people don't like Soul playing
Soul Plane the hood classic it's
definitely a hood classical I sold
copies of it as a young child
uh that's how you got named boot that
kill yes for sure precisely sir respect
sole plane put Kevin Hart on don't you
ever forget it definitely
first Kevin Hart movie I remember
watching I mean silver plain me too Tom
Arnold was in Soul Plane that was his
last great moment too yeah so playing do
you know who Tom Arnold is no you ever
watch Roseanne nope damn we grew up
different I'm telling you a lot of
movies a lot of movies you probably like
no Roseanne with the white lady and the
her
her [__] families from like the like
the 90s it was probably it was like a
sitcom about a family the Connors no you
never seen it was that jeez what TV
shows besides 106 and Park did you like
well what are you watching right now do
you watch do you like binge watch
anything or are you on Netflix checking
out documentaries yeah I like um
manifest I heard manifest is good yeah
Manifesto I just finished manifest
um
that's the [__] is oh Tyree
the the ghost series retiree that's your
dog oh ghost okay yeah I'm rocking with
that
um I missed the whole Power Wave this
week it's a couple I got in this crazy I
got on the power with with the ghost
series like the little tired right she
went back yeah um
it's a couple honestly but I know
manifest probably like the best thing
going right now manifest manifest I just
finished snowfall I was rocking with
snowfall everything I was really
watching though it just came to the end
like season finales and [__] so I'm
really trying to find new [__] to watch
I love snowfall yeah snowfall had me
wondering what crack would be like to
take you know
but it definitely made me be like
because you know there's like the the
part of the show where
um
Franklin Saints girlfriend smokes crack
the cop's daughter yeah and in one
episode her whole [__] just gets
everything just went outside she ends up
like in a [__] crazy they say that
having sex selling her dad's jewelry and
I'm like damn I said that first hit that
first hit like so it just makes you
wonder like
you feel me like is it good I ain't
gonna lie a crackhead told me that first
hit
is like I think they're like chasing it
the rest of their life yeah you know
what I'm saying and then they end up you
know naked I'll make her show over here
come on get it out the first hit you
know what I'm saying okay
are there a lot of homeless people in
Jacksonville
yes a lot of homeless people everywhere
I imagine no there's a lot of homeless
people here you can do something about
it listen here you're in L.A we got we
are like the [__] LeBron James
the homeless people bro this is so crazy
I just we are the goddamn Coca-Cola of
the homeless I'll be wishing I could do
something about it man we're like on the
street but I know I know it's it it's
going it's gone one day what is it I
gotta ask you right because your guys's
Governor is probably gonna he's running
for president Ron DeSantis and he has a
lot of divisive policies about he's
banned uh certain black studies in the
universities and
he's trying to ban all the wokeness any
thoughts on Rhonda said this little Papa
uh you actually just run out into my
attention you know what I'm saying first
person bring into my attention but I
mean
we just I just look at it like is
everything good in Florida like when
you're living there are you like I like
the way he's running [__] exactly not
because or I don't I don't notice the
policies yeah because I don't live in
Florida no more he's a smart man I'm
just yeah I'm just from you know what
I'm saying so it's like I don't really
be normal I feel like especially if
you're from Jacksonville once you get
popping get the [__] out of there
respectfully of course you know maybe go
back if you guys you know go to the
playoffs or something
that game was it against the Chargers
gaffy that game this year yeah
of the year I mean I was at that game
yeah it made me be like okay that's why
they did that because you were there
yeah you're the lucky charm yeah
well you're not yeah you're not I mean
you're you're like uh yeah you said was
that was that said correctly I didn't
just call you a leprechaun yeah I said
lucky charm
yeah they did that wow shout out to the
job while they they had me a little
Jersey though when I got that little
Papa you know what I'm saying that's
fireman yeah what's your favorite cereal
speaking of Lucky Charms fruity pelvis
Fruity Pebbles are gas Fruity Pebbles
and then you got to go Frosted Flakes
all right uh have you ever been at the
bottom of a bunch of cereal at the same
time like all the cereals are low and
then you just combine them into like a
Super Bowl of cereals yeah mess around
with Q3 that [__] is fire I had no
choice
it's kind of like would that kind of
like a be a decent analogy of your new
album it's like the super cereal bow of
hip-hop right now
yeah exactly you see I'm Number well at
number six it's your sixth album no I'm
talking about wow
um on Apple music yeah congratulations I
appreciate that it was a headache I'm
trying to go top five you will
what you got to do is you just gotta
like you know yeah we're gonna try to
get top five I don't care if anybody
wants buy it again real talk and got it
pushed up it's man go top five it just
came out Friday yeah it just came out
Friday only one week of promo too what
has been your uh like you know when you
usually drop an album you'll notice
feedback about like do what song you
getting the most feedback on that you
feel like is a fan favorite
um
surprisingly
probably like I've been seeing a lot of
can't find it and problems back home
problems back home probably back home
but I wasn't surprised that that was
going to be a fan favorite right
I had them posted
um a little clip of the song and they
was asking for how many uh videos have
you shot or I'm sure you got some in the
can got two already well three already
released stopped going Mia
my Nova Mata and Chrome Heart make sure
y'all go check them I keep screaming
them up and then I got um do you like to
wear Chrome Heart Clothing yeah all
right we're crawling so I was at uh the
mall in Vegas like two days ago yeah at
the win
and they had a Chrome Heart store in
there yeah and I walked in there and I
said
I'm gonna give this cheesy ass cornhart
[__] a chance and I went in there
and I just I just couldn't do it man I
feel like I would have walked out of
there dressed like Chris Jericho or
something
you just gotta know how to see the thing
is this is the thing right is a lot of
people can wear the designer
but I would have the designer wearing me
type [__] that's what I'm saying I like
a pro club actually got to be in you not
on you it's definitely you feel me the
designer thing is not on me or in me see
that's what I'm saying now you can get
you a stylist if you feel like that see
I'm 36 with with children yeah and I
feel like the the fitted and the tea and
the nice pair of shoes yeah
is kind of just where I'm at in life
yeah like see me if I was like at the
Grammys yeah I would see if Pro Club
could make me a suit
you know just give me the Pro Club soup
that's real see me I'll be on some [__]
on some chill [__] I don't really be on
I don't like dressing up news you know
what I'm saying like you see me it's a
great Vape sweater you guys appreciate
it you feel me it's chill [__] I go get
me some
what is your advice in terms of what you
spend the most money on it that is
irresponsible
they like to go to restaurants a lot
which is mine obviously I'm fine you see
me uh some people like sneakers which is
another bicycle some people like cars
jewelry what is your biggest like I like
to splurge on this all right sneakers
clothes sneakers Jordans fashion
um yeah yeah Jordans I'm a [__] [__]
head so Jordan I'm one of them people
that feel like I gotta get every pill
Joy like every Jordan yeah I got to that
point about a month ago and uh I looked
at my my man cave and it's just full of
shoes and I was just like mm-hmm these
fools just got there me too they got me
I just did that I just cleaned out my
car I was like I'm not even gonna win it
did the same [__] yep I did the same
[__] I'm gonna get majority of them away
though you know what I'm saying back to
the city you should sell them or or
donate them yeah yeah I'm gonna donate
them and then I got a son now too so you
got to get every Jordan how old is
yourself one one yeah
has he shat on you yet
so that's not on my hand but you ever
had anything out of my hand one thing
about me yeah he did me you feed me way
better than he did his mom like
hmm [__] on me I got shot on my kid yeah
he pissed but that's about it other than
that yeah yeah other than that mom's got
to work yeah
would you say having a kid kind of
change the way you look at the world and
the show priorities the show
definitely and it made me go 10 times
harder yeah